Drouet Foster McKeon eldest son of
Christian rapper TobyMac has died at the
age of 21 according to a statement from
a representative for TobyMac on Thursday
true it passed away at home in the
Nashville area Wednesday morning his
cause of death has not been determined
the statement goes on to explain that
Toby was traveling back from Canada and
did not get to be with his family
until after midnight last night so there
is no statement his rep asks that
everyone please be respectful of the
family's privacy and allow them to
grieve their loss prior to his death
true was following in his famous
father's footsteps as an aspiring rapper
releasing a number of songs and videos
on YouTube
his father whose real name is Kevin
McKee Han wrote the song scars for him
[Music]
in October 2018 Toby opened up to The
Tennessean about his son moving to LA to
make music quote to watch him go through
that and watch him get bruised
it's not easy adding quote I just want
him to know he's not alone
[Music]